[Musique]
lhassa la capitale du tibet la ville
interdite qui faisait rêver jadis
explorateurs et voyageurs de nos jours
l'ancien fief des dalaï lama et
l'orgueil des colons chinois est le
passage obligé pour se rendre dans
n'importe quelle région du tibet
match nul
depuis 40 ans l'ethnologue michel
peissel parcours l'asie centrale à la
recherche de cultures et de mode de vie
en voie de disparition
il entreprend aujourd'hui une nouvelle
expédition un voyage dans l'inconnu au
fin fond du tibet dans une région
interdite
la plus haute de notre planète
à l'heure où les tibétains se mettent à
l'internet peut-il rester encore quelque
chose à découvrir dans ce pays occupé
par les chinois est survolée par des
satellites
oui il y a dans le nord ouest du pays un
territoire immense encore inexplorés
[Musique]
là ça a tout d'une ville moderne ces
grands magasins ses buildings
pourtant on y rencontre encore des
hommes d'une autre époque des nomades en
pèlerinage qui évoque un tibet bien
différent
ces hommes et ces femmes ont les mêmes
visages que ce que rencontrèrent il ya
un siècle les tout premiers européens en
traversant le haut plateau tibétain le
changtang
[Musique]
l'expédition la plus remarquée fut celle
des français gabriel bonvalot et henri
d'orléans
étrangement depuis personne n'a eu la
curiosité de pousser plus loin
l'exploration de cette région située à
plus de 5000 mètres d'altitude
[Musique]
les régions inexplorées sont presque
toujours interdite
il faudra obtenir de l'occupant chinois
11 permis spéciaux pour traverser les
six provinces et les cinq zones
militaires qui sépare la sa de l'extrême
nord ouest
au total six mois de négociations et un
voyage de reconnaissance avant de
pouvoir enfin se mettre en route
[Musique]
départ début octobre deux camions et de
4,4 18 jerrycans d'essence une tonne de
vivres 10 kg de médicaments des tentes
et des bonbonnes d'oxygène indispensable
en cas d'urgence voilà pour la
logistique
l'équipe compte 16 personnes 12
tibétains et quatre étrangers dont une
seule femme
frédéric d'aragon qui sera la
photographe de l'expédition
elle est spécialiste du tibet et par le
chinois
nous quittons enfin là ça cette fois
l'aventuré commence
nous longerons pendant 300 km la face
nord de la chaîne himalayenne jusqu'au
pied de l'everest en suivant la vallée
du brahmapoutre après quoi nous
piqueront droit vers le nord pour gagner
le haut plateau
un seul un des coéquipiers est un indien
péruvien de l'altiplano son physique le
fera souvent passer pour un riche
réfugiés tibétains vivent en amérique la
vallée du brahmapoutre et le grenier à
auch du tibet et elle abrite aussi les
plus grands monastères comme celui de
sakya
non
à
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes encore pour l'instant dans
le tibet classique celui des moines et
des agriculteurs pour accéder au tibet
méconnu qui nous attend nous devons
franchir le grand fleuve le brahmapoutre
qui s'appelle ici le thang peau
c'est maintenant que l'expédition
commence vraiment maintenant que nous
songeons avec beaucoup d'excitation et
un peu d'angoissé à ce mystérieux au
plateau que les cartes indiqué avec
cette mention inexplorés
[Musique]
nous devrons le traversée du sud au nord
jusqu'au pied des monts queen longue qui
marque la frontière avec le désert de
taklamakan
un parcours de 2400 km la distance de
paris à moscou
[Musique]
nous sommes tous conscients de plongée
dans l'inconnu
pas question de tomber en panne ici ce
monde n'est pas fait pour les inventions
modernes c'est celui des drogues pas les
nomades qui ne se déplacent qu'à pied ou
à cheval
première difficulté s'habituer au froid
ici il neige en été il grêle en hiver et
il gèle tous les jours de l'année
octobre est le seul mois où l'on peut
espérer échapper au pire intempérie
garde c'est la dernière garnison
chinoise sur notre route nous devons y
faire contrôlé nos papiers
[Musique]
comme toutes les villes frontières garde
ce n est qu une sinistre vitrine de la
civilisation moderne est un lieu de
détention pour les opposants au régime
chinois
[Musique]
c'est pour nous la dernière étape dans
un monde à peu près familier l'occasion
de faire le plein de carburant d'acheter
l'indispensable et le superflu et de
prendre une ultime douche
et
nous voilà livrer nous mêmes désormais
si nos camions nous lâche personne ne
viendra nous chercher
sur les contreforts du haut-plateau
enfin un paysage qui ressemble aux
descriptions que nous avons lu un désert
glacé ou des animaux galope librement ce
sont des kings
les plus grands hommes sauvages du monde
aussi emblématique du tibet que le yak
ici à 4600 mètres d'altitude on entre
dans un univers minéral née du choc de
deux continents
la croûte terrestre est deux fois plus
épaisse que dans le reste du monde
les sources chaudes jaillissent de
toutes parts et le sol est jonché de
fossiles marins qui atteste que le fond
de la mer a bien été projetée vers le
ciel il y à quelque 65 millions d'années
[Musique]
partout sur le haut plateau des lacs
salés dont les abords sont de véritables
gisements de sel minéraux bohrium
lithium celle d'uranium et sel
comestible fond avec la potasse et lors
la richesse de ses terres dénudées
[Musique]
la partie sud du haut plateau et le
domaine des tribus nomades éleveuse de
yack domestiquer pense-t-on il y a huit
mille ans le yaka une agilité de chèvre
et une résistance à toute épreuve il
peut franchir des cols de plus de 6000
mètres en transportant de lourdes
charges
il fournit bien sûr viande lait beurre
mais en outre son poil sert à fabriquer
des tentes des cordes et des couvertures
et sa blouse et le seul combustible de
disponible dans ce désert dépourvu
d'arbres et de buissons
[Musique]
ces nomades sont les derniers hommes
libres du tibet les descendants de cette
race de roy qui depuis des millénaires
inquiète les agriculteurs sédentaires et
les citadins c'est contre des peuples
errant comme eux que fut édifiée la
grande muraille de chine
ici une caravane qui se rend en
pèlerinage à lhassa il nous à vis de
l'état des pistes de la hauteur de neige
sur l'école en échange il nous interroge
sur le court de la laine à lhassa nous
sommes bien en peine de leur répondre
michel les questionne sur la tribu de
chasseurs nomades pratiquement inconnu
que nous cherchons des sengoku n'en
n'ont apparemment jamais entendu parler
dans les années 60
la chine a tenté de sédentariser les
nomades entraînant une terrible famine
et la mort de bon nombre d'entre eux
après ce désastre et les exactions des
gardes rouges ils ont retrouvé la
liberté de suivre leurs troupeaux et
repris leur mode de vie lui fois
millénaire
il
on n'allait pas
regardez
ouais
[Musique]
c'est en en poils de yack son était
comme hiver le seul abri des nomades
sous la tente les seuls divertissement
sont les visites et les conversations
autour d'une tasse de thé ce fameux thé
tibétains et aromatisé au beurre de yak
et au sel les seuls visiteurs sont
généralement d'autres nomades la venue
du groupe d'étrangers que nous sommes
est un événement michel demande à ce
jeune homme quel est le nom de sa tribu
mais celui ci ne semble pas avoir
compris la question quel est votre tribu
cinq autres sont pas si famille lorca
savez quel âge avez vous lowy look
skinhead 30 ans mariée depuis six mois
jérôme hamon environnement
les tentes en laine de yack offre une
protection bien fragile dans l'air glacé
du haut-plateau la longue ouverture au
sommet certes à l'évacuation de la fumée
car pour essayer de se réchauffer les
nomades entretiennent presque
constamment un feu avec de la bouse de
yak
d autres activités quotidiennes
essentiel sous la tente
le barattage du yaourt pour faire du
beurre
m
selon ce porte parole
qu'on bâillonne de son auto michel
demande si nous avons des chances de
voir par ici les antilopes et dgac
sauvage le jeune homme explique qu'il
faut monter beaucoup plus haut vers le
nord
y at il des grizzlies n'ont pas beaucoup
en ce moment surtout en été et en hiver
exhibait rne
plus on s'avance dans l'immense espace
du changtang plus on a l'impression de
parcourir un paysage inédit un paradis
sauvage dont on aurait caché l'existence
au reste du monde
ces silhouettes au galop sont des
antilopes tibétaines dette chez vous
c'est avec leur toison d'or qu'on
fabrique le chat touche la laine des
rois la plus fine la plus chaude est la
plus chère du monde
rare privilège que de voir ces animaux
fugace ils seront désormais nos
compagnons de voyage
[Musique]
[Rires]
lors de notre voyage de reconnaissance
nous avions découvert ici un lieu sacré
dont l'entrée est indiquée par ces
drapeaux
renseignements pris il s'agit d'une
grotte qui au viiie siècle aurait servi
de refuge à un héros de l'épopée
tibétaine khezar de ling lors d'une
chasse royale oiac sauvage ce sanctuaire
souterrain abrite une sorte d'autel
jonché de cornes offrande de chasseurs
ou de chaman à la déesse de la chance tu
es des yaks sauvage est un fait banal
aujourd'hui surtout depuis l'invasion
des chinois qui les abattent massivement
pour nourrir leurs armes et les immenses
troupeaux ont disparu de toutes les
régions accessible
[Musique]
un peu plus loin au milieu de ce désert
une incroyable vision
[Musique]
le découvrons que ces étranges igloo de
terre
sont les camps d'hiver des nomades sango
la tribu que nous recherchons
à 5000 mètres d'altitude ce sont les
habitations les plus hautes de notre
planète
nous les trouvons vide les 5go s'y
réfugier au plus froid de l'hiver en été
ils sont ailleurs
mais où et comment trouver sur un
territoire grand comme la moitié de la
france une peuplade qui compte à peine
2000 âmes
[Musique]
nous trouvons enfin les nomades que nous
cherchons dans un lieu étrange un
village de vieillards de morts-vivants
c'est un campement où les nomades singo
abandonne les vieillards dès qu'ils
deviennent trop faible pour suivre la
transhumance des troupeaux peut-être
pourront-ils nous aider à retrouver la
trace de leurs familles
les voilà qu'ils sortent un à un de
leurs ruches des morts-vivants peut-être
mais très curieux et pas triste du tout
ils sont ravis de revoir frédéric qui
leur a apporté les photos prises l'année
précédente
[Musique]
pendant que nous montons les tentes
jacques falck le médecin de l'expédition
va essayer de soigner les maux de ces
vieillards comme on dit docteur chico
gamme qui avait attiré ilan où il a un
traumatisme peut-être tué maggie may
treanor un de nos chauffeurs à quelques
réparations à faire sur son vieux
camions pendant ce temps nous achetons
un mouton que nos autres veulent bien tu
es préparer pour nous qui donnera des
matches
elle
celle enfin de la viande fraîche pour
changer de la viande de gak sécher que
frédéric a acheté à lhassa la monotonie
de nos menus mais à part nous n'avons
pas trop pas nous plaindre sauf du froid
et de l'altitude
il fait moins 20 degrés la nuit nous
approchons désormais des 5000 m et la
raréfaction de l'oxygène nous épuisent
le moindre geste nous demande un effort
nous ne pouvons pas nous attarder
il nous reste plus de 800 kilomètres à
parcourir pour atteindre le pied des
monts queen longue et la piste se
termine ici on nous a indiqué vaguement
vers le nord un endroit assez lointain
où les 5go ont l'habitude de camper à
nous de trouver les passages
les vieillards retournent à leur
solitude
[Musique]
plus de routes plus de cartes
il faut maintenant la vidéo gps avec
pour seul repère les satellites et faire
preuve de sagacité pour deviner les
meilleurs moyens de contourner les
obstacles les lacs salés qui se
succèdent et les chaînes de montagne qui
les sépare
tous les êtres vivants rencontrés ici
ont quelque chose d'exceptionnel cwa à
barres sont les astronautes de la nature
chaque année elles franchissent à tire
d'aile la chaîne de l'himalaya pour
regagner leurs quartiers d'hiver des
pilotes de ligne en ont croisé à 10000
mètres d'altitude volant par moins 80
degrés à la limite de la troposphère
pour permettre cet exploit leur coeur
bat à 400 pulsations minute
[Musique]
nous devenons de td td td
au bout de plusieurs heures de route au
bord d'un lac
une rencontre inespérée cette étrange
équipage est une caravane de sel de
nomades sango leurs bêtes de somme sont
des moutons une espèce apprivoiser six
mille ans avant les chevaux il y à 700
bêtes dans cette caravane qui fait route
vers le sud
il leur faudra un mois pour rejoindre
les villages des agriculteurs où ils
échangeront contre de l'orge le celles
prélevées ici au bord des lacs
ce troc est essentiel pour les saints go
sans orge
il ne pourrait survivre sur cette terre
hostile où l'on ne trouve ni fruits ni
légumes la viande et le lait fourni par
les bêtes sont insuffisants pour
affronter des conditions climatiques
aussi extrêmes comme il faut une journée
entière pour charger les sept cents
moutons
ceux ci resteront battait jour et nuit
pendant toute la durée du voyage
[Musique]
point
il suffit de cinq hommes son chien pour
mener à bon port les sept tonnes de sel
chargé sur les moutons une rentabilité
incontestable et cela fait plus de cinq
mille ans que ce commerce existe mais
pour combien de temps encore
[Musique]
dans ces régions glacial un ou deux
mètres sous terre
le sol est perpétuellement geler les
spécialistes appellent ça le permafrost
un piège pour les véhicules trop lourd
parfois sous la croûte sèche du sol se
cachent des lacs de boue nous avons
percé cette croûte et nous risquons de
perdre notre camion
[Musique]
il nous faudra cinq heures pour
l'extraire de ce bourbier un travail
harassant à 5300 mètres d'altitude
comme s'il ne suffisait pas d'être
enlisé nous sommes aussi perdu ne peut
bien être le campement cingo qu'on a
indiqué chacun de nous a son idée sur la
question
[Musique]
c'est ce troupeau de chèvres qui va nous
mettre sur la voie ce sont des kills les
fameux chèvre tibétaine qui fournissent
la laine cachemire
voici enfin ces visages que si peu
d'occidentaux ont vu des hommes dont la
vie n'a pas changé depuis des
millénaires
nous expliquons que nous aimerions voir
des drogués des yaks sauvage cet homme
veut bien nous servir de guide
il s'appelle nima
[Musique]
d
non
[Musique]
les quelques jours que nous passons sous
la tente des saints go sont comme un
voyage dans un lointain passé
il nous semble incarner l'homme dans ce
qu'il a de plus vrai l'homme pour qui le
confort n'a pas remplacé la joie de
vivre et de chanter
[Musique]
nous
m
[Musique]
avertie par nos hôtes des voisins
viennent nous voir
la plupart d'entre eux n'ont jamais
rencontré d'européens mais ils ne sont
nullement intimidé spontanément les
hommes se mettent à danser
[Musique]
elle est là qu à
dégagé
[Musique]
nous poursuivons droit vers le nord
heureux d'avoir enfin rencontrer les 5
go et pressé de repartir au devant de
l'inconnu à la recherche des yaks
sauvage
les antilopes tibétaines sont de plus en
plus nombreuses à mesure que nous
montons vers le nord bien des mystères
entourent encore c'est chiroux dans la
toison est si précieuse
au printemps les femelles vont se cacher
pour mettre bas
nul ne sait où
on ne connaît pas non plus l'itinéraire
de plusieurs milliers de kilomètres
qu'elles suivent chaque année à la
recherche de pâturages
[Musique]
à
ces dates de pierres dressées en
entonnoir sont des pièges datant de
l'âge de pierre
ces terrains de chasse sont jonchées de
silex taillés qui atteste de la présence
millénaire de l'homme sur ce plateau
un mouvement au loin attiré notre
attention
ce sont deux chasseurs d'antilopes
accompagné d'un jeune garçon des
chasseurs 5 go
[Musique]
ils viennent probablement du campement
que nous repérons plus loin mais nous ne
les reverront pas car ils chassent
illégalement et ont très peur de se
faire prendre
les antilopes tibétaines sont protégés
par les lois internationales qui
interdisent le commerce de la laine chat
touche au marché noir
une peau s'achète 600 $ et un châle
10000 dollars mais si les saints go
n'ont plus le droit de chasser les
antilopes sont devenus le monopole d'une
mafia chinoise qui parcourt le plateau
armés de mitraillettes pour alimenter ce
trafic illégal la mafia punit sévèrement
les braconniers et les familles des
chasseurs vivent elles aussi dans la
crainte
notre incursion dans l'attenté frais
cette femme qui croit reconnaître dans
notre étrange physionomie des officiels
chinois
pas tout d'ici 2012
comme dans les salles qui mènent leur
coup de pouce de large
d'abord pour la voir chanter c'est pas
top teams bas nous sommes ici parmi une
tribu de chasseurs une société datant
d'avant l'agriculture et l'élevage
c'est comme si nous avions remonté le
temps jusqu'à la préhistoire
seule nouveauté moderne un métier à
tisser comme ceux qui étaient en usage
il y a trois mille ans
[Applaudissements]
les femmes tissent la laine d'antilopes
après l'avoir teinte avec des couleurs
végétales les motifs ressemblent à ceux
qui ornent les habits des momies de
tchétchènes vieille de 4000 ans trouvait
non loin d'ici de l'autre côté démon
queen longue
autre outil moderne
ce fusil à mèche un modèle dont l'usagé
a disparu en france
au 16ème siècle quand le silex et le
chien de fusil ont remplacé la messe
juive qui ne marchait que par beau temps
[Musique]
ces pièges à antilopes sont paraît-il
plus efficace que le fusil ce sont des
lamelles en corne qui coince le pied des
bêtes et le piège lui même est fixé
aussi avec une cornes d'antilopes car
ici le bois est un matériau inconnu
interview
nous
nous laissons le camp pour reprendre
notre route vers les monts queen longue
guidés par nima nous partons cette fois
en quête de gros gibier voir et filmé
des drogues dgac sauvage est un rêve qui
nous obsède une carcasse de yack sauvage
il a probablement été tués par des loups
car les chasseurs ne s'aventurent guère
par ici et il n'aurait pas abandonné un
aussi beau trophée
cette découverte prouve que nous sommes
sur le bon chemin
les yaks doivent être sur ces montagnes
il faudra donc laisser les véhicules et
partir à pied sur cette pente pierreuse
dénard des chamois du tibet encore une
espèce que nous n'avons jamais vu encore
ce sentiment étrange et émouvant de
foule et une terre vierge
[Musique]
nima n'a pas son pareil pour repérer les
animaux c'est lui aussi qui nous fait
remarquer c'est perdreaux
enfin à 5600 mètres au loin un yack
sauvage solitaire commence une épuisante
poursuites
le yak franchi une première crête et
rejoint un troupeau d'une quarantaine de
bêtes en train d'escalader un col à 6000
m inutile d'essayer de l'approcher ils
sont trop loin
nous sommes exténué déçu par cette
vision si éphémère
[Musique]
à chacun de nos pas la steppe révèle sa
richesse jamais nous n'aurions imaginé
rencontrer une faune aussi variés ici
tout se passe à découvert au vu et au su
de tous faute de perchoirs les aigles
niche à même le sol
[Musique]
les gazelles doivent se méfier d'un
prédateur qui s'est fort bien se fondre
dans le paysage
le coin on l'appelle aussi le loup rouge
une espèce très rare
[Musique]
à
ce sont ces gazelles qui vont nous
conduire au seigneur des hauts plateaux
[Musique]
aiac aiac sauvage et pas du tout
contents de nous voir
un géant parmi les bovidés avec ses 2
mètres au garrot il est plus grand que
le bison d'amérique et le buffle
d'afrique
[Musique]
je
vous
[Musique]
c'est là un moment unique de notre
expédition
ne verront plus jamais un yack d'aussi
près par contre nous apercevrons dans le
lointain des troupeaux entiers toujours
en marche comme les gazelles et des
antilopes en marche parce que c'est la
condition sine qua none pour survivre
ici l'herbe est si rare qu'il faut
constamment se mettre en quête de
nouveaux pâturages grâce à nîmes à nous
allons de surprise en surprise
il a aperçu des marmottes et nous
verrons bientôt aussi leur redoutable
prédateur le voici
c'est le grizzly tibétains
nous avons le privilège d'être les
premiers à filmer dans son milieu
le grizzly tibétains un des ours les
plus rares de la planète
[Musique]
le grizzly tibétain est réputé très
dangereux car bizarrement et ne craint
pas l'homme
[Musique]
ce soir un vent glacial s'est levé nous
campons pour la dixième fois au dessus
de 5000 m épuisé mais heureux de tout ce
que nous avons vu la nuit tombe très tôt
dans ces régions si bien que les soirées
sous la tente nous paraissent
interminables
elles sont cependant l'occasion de
discuter en toute tranquillité de nos
découvertes de la journée je veux savoir
si les aussi dern qui me fait froid qui
convient à tous mais il y en a sauvé sur
ce plan qui ont des crédits dans la
nature il se lève et yack sauvage
hélas son corps ça c'est dangereux
le yak nos élites et les distances les
pensées pour jeu guère de maistre de
type la bombe jeudi raymond de choses à
voir
pour la nuit et la bouillotte je m'en
fiche du à 18h55 de sam & company
[Applaudissements]
au réveil notre cauchemar se réalise
nous sommes en egée pas un rayon de
soleil pour nous réchauffer il fait
moins 20 degrés
[Musique]
non
le haut plateau est devenue une étendue
uniformément blanche et glacée sans
repères on peut craindre de tomber à
nouveau dans la boue du permafrost
[Musique]
à
encore 200 km à parcourir jusqu'à la
chaîne du queens longue
le fin fond des terres inconnues du
tibet
[Musique]
peu à peu le soleil a effacé la neige
nous retrouvons un monde féerique
les grues à tête noire le ciel immense
et les lac turquoise
voilà pourquoi nous tenions tant à venir
jusqu'ici pour voir de nos yeux cet éden
d'où l'homme a été bannie par l'altitude
c'est le shangri-la des tibétains le
pays du sacré de la paix le dernier
horizon vierges de la planète
cette step et plus désertes que le
sahara pas une seule âme qui vive
les kings les ânes sauvages nous
apparaissent plus que jamais comme le
symbole des grands espaces et de la
liberté preuve qu'il existe encore bel
et bien un tibet sauvage
[Musique]
nous avons atteint le pied des monts
queen longue
à l'est c'est en un effroyable désert de
pierres nous y ferons juste une
incursion sans nos camions qui s'enlise
ray dans les sables
s'il y avait véritablement un dernier
refuge un paradis perdu
c'est sans aucun doute ici
au-delà de ces montagnes la terre
bascule sur 5000 m de dénivelé vers les
sables torride du taklamakan le tibet
s'achève ici en même temps que notre
expédition
mais il en faudra beaucoup d'autres pour
achever d'étudier la faune
extraordinaire du changtang avec la
découverte d'une nouvelle gazelle et
d'une sous-espèce de klang nous
apportons notre contribution à
l'exploration de la plus grande région
encore vierge de notre planète
la venue de l'hiver et des tempêtes nous
oblige à repartir
oh là bas
au niveau
nous sommes heureux d'avoir pu parcourir
le dernier eden l'ultime paradis perdu
où plus de 200 mille animaux sauvages
vivent encore comme au premier jour de
la création
[Musique]
ah ah
colas
ah bon
à côté
oh
à
[Musique]
un bas